year for the first time in 43 years the
nfl regular season expands this time
from 16 to 17 games he's peter king i'm
mike florio we'll be talking about that
and more
over the course of the next hour good
afternoon peter how are you
mike i was just thinking today that i
was a senior at ohio university
when the nfl first played a 16-game
regular season
and i'm just mind-boggled
that i've gone pretty much my entire
adult life
with the nfl never changing the schedule
until today
so you're right is it it is a historic
day
i was in the eighth grade and i'm never
batted an eye about
14 to 16. it's just hey more football
that's great
and the only consideration that i ever
saw in the newspaper at the time was
that the records
based on 14 games would be in grave
danger
with 16 games no talk of health and
safety although there was never any talk
of health and safety at the time of the
players
this time peter the nfl's wanted this
for more than a decade
it took a very long time to finesse this
but it was
last march when the nfl secured the
ability via the
latest collective bargaining agreement
to expand the regular season
by 16 to 17 games that we knew what was
going to happen the question was would
they implement it right away
or would they bump it until this year
and we've known
for months you had weeks ago that's why
it was so bizarre out of nowhere on
sunday it's like it's news the nfl is
going to do this anyone's been paying
attention
knew for weeks months this was happening
today's the day the rubber stamp gets
applied to the piece of paper
mike there's a couple of things i i i
mean look
i am no fan of extra games because
all i've heard for years around the nfl
is
health and safety health and safety and
you know you just can't tell me when you
play
six percent more regular season snaps
that your players are going to be
healthier it's just
it's nonsensical but be that as it may
be that as it may i got a great kick
on sunday of alvin kamara of the saints
basically
ripping going to going to 17 games
and look there's a lot of players who
are ripping going to 17 games
but mike 1019
players voted for the new agreement
that said let's play 17 games
you know so all of the people
who say that this ridiculous league
doesn't care lee
and all this stuff the players had a
chance to do something about it
and didn't do that you can blame d smith
if you want go ahead
you can blame anybody i don't care who
you blame
but the fact is 32
players in every locker room
on average voted for the new cba
and that new cba had a provision in it
that allowed the nfl at as soon as
2021 to play a 17-game regular season
so that's why i'm befuddled
when i hear people now ripping the
concept of it
you should have ripped it last march
14th
before this vote went down and and it
makes no sense to do it now and it does
no good to do it now
as i said the other day in my column
mike it is almost like
you hate the outcome of a presidential
election
and you know a year later you're saying
hey wait a second
i hate this new president we have in
office let's get him out of there
you had a chance to get him out of there
on the day of the election
and he didn't do it so the way this
country works this guy is the president
for the next four years
you can do something about it in four
years but not right now
in other words peter hates the president
who's currently in office i think that's
the takeaway
from what you just said mean i'm kidding
um
here's what i'll i'll say to this
the nfl was getting 17 games
it was happening whether it happened
through
a vote last march 2020 that ratified the
cba that had been carefully negotiated
for months between union leadership
and the league or if the nflpa
rank and file had voted it down peter it
was happening through
whatever economic pressure the league
would bring to bear on the players
off-season lockout that lingers into the
season because
at the end of the day there is a clear
imbalance
in the power
between the two sides in that the league
will always be willing to shut the sport
down
for a year to get what it wants the
players
as we learned in 1987 and as we've
learned every time
since will not keep a strike going
will not even start a strike will not
tolerate a lockout that causes them to
miss
any games when you have that gross
imbalance
where one side has the nuclear option
and the other side won't use it
and one side will the owners were
getting 17 games the only question was
was it going to be done without a work
stoppage or was it going to be done
with a work stoppage that would have
lasted in the offseason like we saw
10 years ago so it was coming it wasn't
a matter of of
a vote or regret over the outcome of the
vote
one way or the other it was happening
two observations one if the nfl players
did not vote
for this new cba in march 2020
uh the the players either would have
been locked out as of right now
or they'd be on their way to a lockout
this year
that's number one second observation
there would be no billion dollar
new media extension of all
tv and streaming contracts never would
have happened
because there was not the certainty
of continuous football
and so that is why the reason why
uh the nfl has struck it rich in the
last month with
all the tv and streaming deals is
because
they know that there will be games for
the next decade
uninterrupted and mike as i say
players had a chance to do something
about it didn't do it
so complaining now is just is crying
over
spilled milk right and when we know that
the thing that they ultimately could do
they would never do
this is where we are and i think that
that that's why
that mike you you were about to say and
i'm sorry i stole your thunder
d smith negotiates with one hand tied
behind his back
he does he knows that his players
don't have the gumption to to strike
and so he knows that he can go
to a certain distance he can go so far
and these you know i really get a kick
out of the people who say d smith is so
weak
i mean walk a mile in his shoes
and understand that the reason if you
think he's weak
the reason he's weak is because his
players
do not give him uh
the basically the strength to go into
negotiations
by saying dee we got your back we'll go
on strike if you tell us
they won't do it that's absolutely right
and i think from dee's perspective he
recognized there are two ways
to do this and this would have all been
a realization he had at some point
during the 2019 season when the
negotiations began there's two ways to
do it
we can do it in a way that we negotiate
we get a fair deal we move forward
uninterrupted we lay the foundation
for long-term big money
revenue from the networks that we share
currently with the nfl or we can get
into a big fight
and we know how the fight's going to end
if you know how the fight's going to
end why do you go into a fight that can
harm the collective business interest
and
impede for example the finalization of
the media contracts
keep everyone from having the long-term
certainty that the league now has
that money people act like that money is
only going into the pockets of the
owners
that money gets shared with the players
and i've seen people say oh well they
waited to announce these deals until
after the salary cap went down
look that money's future money and they
can move as much of it around as they
want
they're still going to share it whenever
it hits the books
the league and the owners share the
money with the players now so i i agree
with you completely
and if the players for for a union that
will never
strike and never accept a lockout that
causes the players to miss games they're
doing pretty damn well
for not using their nuclear option
i'm amazed the owners don't run
roughshod over them even more peter
yeah i agree mike i don't
you make it very clear they're not
negotiating with one hand
tied behind their back they're
negotiating you know with two
because obviously d smith understands
what his rank and file won't
do and again look you know
the players in the nfl are a lot like
the citizens
of the united states there are a lot
of different uh you know a lot of
different things
a lot of different constituencies that d
smith represents the minimum salary guys
don't want to miss five minutes and
because there are so many minimum salary
guys
they hold a lot of sway and they carry a
lot of power
when you go in with 2400 players voting
or
however many there were eligible i think
if i'm not mistaken right mike
they had about 2 000 players vote almost
2 000
vote and they had like 450
that did not vote so they they had maybe
82 or something percent turn out i
forget what it was
but in essence you're still talking
about at least
on average 32 players per team
on the 32 teams voted to
approve the 17th game
and it's a stew of competing interest as
you say the older players the younger
players the players making not much
money
the players making a lot of money the
younger players who are stuck under a
wage scale
and the the strangest dynamic of all
you got 90 players maximum on the
offseason roster
in what other unionized workforce does
more than 40 percent
of the workforce get laid off
simultaneously
in one fell swoop on labor day weekend
ironically
on labor day weekend more than 40
percent of the labor force in the nfl is
told
please leave and then they're just out
there searching for any scraps they can
get and and that that so it's it's a
mess
it's a mess and and you know what peter
last thing before we talk more about the
expansion the regular season
if they had not extended the cba
last year the salary cap this year under
the old agreement would have been like
160 million dollars
so every as bad as it was going from
198.2 to 182.5
it would have been twice as bad if it
had fallen all the way to 160. so
look you if you're going to criticize
the union
it's not and and i i've got no horse in
this i've just been around it for 20
years it's not
union leadership it's the rank and file
they are as you said dealing with two
hands behind their back
and it's amazing that owners don't take
even more
advantage of the power that they have so
they've taken advantage of the power to
move to 17 games three preseason games
per team
not a surprise because it's still a 20
game package
back pre-78 when it was 14 regular
season games
six preseason games 20 game package it's
been a 20-game package
for decades they didn't want to give
that up peter
and one more week on the regular season
still starts after labor day
pushes the super bowl back some years it
will coincide with presidents day
weekend assuming they stick with 17
games
i don't think they will for very long
that's a different topic but they got
what they wanted
longer season and we've got more playoff
teams that were implemented as of last
year that was part of the new cba
and and look it's more inventory it's
more money
and as gambling becomes legalized in
more and more states
the nfl is going to be very happy to put
the infrastructure in place
to have more games
no question and mike you just said you
know you
mentioned gambling and how interesting
is it that now
the new uh nate title sponsor
of the superdome you know obviously
is going to be a uh you know a gaming
uh corporation you know gambling
corporation and so
yeah i'll tell you one thing this is a
different nfl
this is not your father's nfl anymore i
remember the first few years i ever
covered this game
i'll tell you what gambling was like
that was this dirty a word gambling on
nfl games
as fixing nfl games was you know
and now it's like hey bring your bring
your gambling money to the four
let's name stadiums after gambling
companies and so
i don't know mike uh you know i think
the one thing
that we've all learned about the nfl
you know a couple of weeks ago when
robert kraft was
was waxing poetic about jeff bezos
in my column you know and talking about
how much he admired bezos and
told him how great he was and everything
like that
is there any business entity
in the united states today that is
better at finding a jillion dollars
under the couch cushion
when you thought that they've gotten
just about all that they could
and all of a sudden hey jeff bezos
come on over here you're my new best
friend
i i i think mark cuban needs to dust off
his old catch phrase and add
something to it it's pigs get fat
hogs get slaughtered boars run wild
because that's what the nfl is and it
is unstoppable and peter i'm telling you
it's just a matter of time before we
start hearing
18 games it's just a matter of time
before we start hearing
expansion all these young quarterbacks
coming in
and showing they can play right away it
results in more quarterbacks who can get
it done at a high level
which justifies more teams we know
there's more than enough position
players
out there thanks to all the major
colleges but if you want to increase
inventory for betting purposes
and you can only make the season so big
well okay more teams hey that's the
safest way to do it it's more jobs it's
good for the union
it's good for the league it's good for
everybody and i'm telling you
i thought it would never happen in our
lifetimes 32 was the number that was
frozen in
i think it's just a matter of time
before we start hearing talk of 34
or more and once we start hearing talk
that's when we know the gears are moving
and it's just a matter of time before
they do it
if we're talking about international
football
i would not be surprised to see an
international division
london london munich and pick another
one
you know because to me i think that that
makes a tremendous
amount of sense london london munich in
mexico city doesn't make sense to me
but that doesn't mean it won't happen uh
but
i would agree with you mike i i will i
would bet
that in our lifetime there's going to be
a division of teams
an international division and that will
be how the nfl expands i don't think
you'll see
the nfl expand to portland oregon
and and to and to lesser american cities
i think you'll see them expand
internationally if they do
yeah i think once they cross that bridge
with one team it makes sense to do it
with two and once you do it with two
why stop there and again all those games
going to be televised
simultaneously around the world they're
developing the technology so there's no
delay whatsoever which is conducive to
real-time betting on a play-by-play
basis
that's when the another jillion dollars
gets found
under the couch cushions once they
implement that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports